la séance est reprise
en application du cinquième alinéa de
l'article 13 de la Constitution ainsi
que de la loi organique et de la loi
ordinaire du 23 juillet 2010 prise pour
son application la commission des
finances à Émile lors de sa réunion de
ce jour un avis favorable 17 voix pour
une voix contre à la reconduction de
Monsieur Nicolas dufourque aux fonctions
de directeur général de la société
anonyme BPI France
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen de la
proposition de résolution relative à la
reconnaissance du génocide
à sirop caldéen de 1915 1918 présenté en
application de l'article 34-1 de la
Constitution par Madame Valérie Boyer
Monsieur Bruno Retailleau et plusieurs
de leurs collègues demandent du groupe
les républicains dans la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Valérie
Boyer auteur de la proposition de
résolution
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
il y a près de huit années je poussais
les portes du Sénat je n'étais pas
présente dans cette émission mais dans
les tribunes
je veux d'ailleurs saluer les
représentants de l'Association des
acérocaldéens de France le président
Marius cyranis François piponi George
joclin les élus tonifidiens et Jean
Samat le professeur et frem ils disent
le président du sefyocenteur s'abriacman
et tous ceux qui n'ont pu être à leur
côté mais qui suivent les débats
permettez-moi de saluer plus
particulièrement le professeur Joseph
Yacoub et son épouse Claire vous êtes
les enfants les rescapés d'une
entreprise de destruction massive d'un
génocide
en effet il y a plus de 11 ans le Sénat
marqué l'histoire en votant les textes
que j'avais porté au Parlement sur la
pénalisation du négationnisme du
génocide de 1915 il y a près de 22 ans
malgré les pressions diplomatiques le
Parlement votait la reconnaissance du
génocide arménien et je n'imaginais pas
à cette époque siégé dans cette émission
les devoirs de nouveau par les d'un
génocide je tiens à remercier tout
particulièrement le président l'archet
d'avoir inscrit à l'ordre du jour cette
résolution portant la reconnaissance du
génocide des acéocaliens de 1915 à 1918
et permettez-moi de remercier tout
particulièrement Bruno Retailleau qui
s'est toujours mobilisée sur ce sujet
ainsi que le président Hervé Marseille
qui a accepté de s'engager à nos côtés
aussi en ce 8 février 2023 j'espère que
nous serons nous rassembler pour une
cause qui nous transcende celle de la
justice et des droits humains pour cette
cause universelle même si l'histoire est
un perpétuel recommencement elle ne doit
pas être un renoncement éternel
c'est la première fois en France que la
question du génocide des acérocaldiens
est soumise à un examen public suivi
d'un vote nous ne le disons pas
suffisamment mais oui le destin l'avenir
de l'Occident et l'avenir de l'Orient
sont intimementés le sort des chrétiens
d'Orient et des autres minorités tels
que les yésidis peut-être considéré
comme un prélude à notre propre sort
aujourd'hui encore les chrétiens
d'Orient sont en danger de mort et nous
sommes les témoins de ce massacre
annoncé et même revendiquer
rappelons-nous le 8 juin 2014 daesh en
Irak et au Levant prenez le contrôle de
la ville de Mossoul l'ancienne Ninive
capitale des empires Assyriens qui
comptait autrefois plus de 30 000
chrétiens à sirocaldéens ces barbares
ont provoqué la fuite de près de 10 000
chrétiens de cette ville dans laquelle
les maisons appartenant à la communauté
acéro caldéenne ont été marquées de la
lettre noun faisant référence au terme
Nazaréen qui désigne les chrétiens ces
derniers ont été sommets de se convertir
à l'islam de Pelé la gisra ou encore de
quitter la ville sans rien emporter avec
sous peine d'être mis à mort la ville se
vidait en quelques jours de toute la
population chrétienne selon l'évangile
de Saint-Luc s'il se taisent les pierres
crieront mais il sera trop tard et
demain qui parlera l'araméen qui parlera
la langue du Christ sans huit ans après
1915 l'histoire bégaye il s'agissait de
l'époque du premier génocide du 20e
siècle perpétré par l’empire ottoman
turc avec plus de 2,5 millions de
victimes chrétiennes d'origine
arménienne acero-calédienne syriaque
pontique effectivement il ne faisait pas
la différence entre eux les motifs
étaient soi-disant laïciste mais c'était
de l'épuration ethnique ils sont
islamistes aujourd'hui mais la méthode
reste exactement la même ce génocide
avait différentes formes rien n'était
épargné il était physique culturel et
culturel plus de la moitié de la
communauté estimée à environ 500 000
membres fut martyrisé ce fut une
politique d'élimination concertée
planifiée appuyé par une abandonne
documentation en plusieurs langues c'est
pourquoi j'avais décidé de déposer dès
1915 à l'Assemblée nationale un texte
relatif à la reconnaissance du génocide
des acérocaldens une proposition de loi
relative à cette reconnaissance que j'ai
redéposé en février 2022 avec Bruno
Retailleau et que nous étions engagés à
inscrire à l'ordre du jour du Sénat ce
que nous avons fait avec cette
résolution et j'apprends aujourd'hui que
mon collègue Raphaël chalberger
vice-président du groupe chrétien
d'Orient vient de redéposer la même
résolution à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui je veux le redire nous avons
un rôle de protection envers les
chrétiens d'Orient qui est l'héritage
d'une longue histoire remontant au
capitulation signée par François 1er
avec le sultan Soliman le Magnifique en
1535 la mémoire et l'histoire contribue
à l'identité des peuples l'oublier la
négation porte atteinte au respect à la
dignité humaine ne laissons pas la
France faillir à son devoir de mémoire
historique et morale de protection des
minorités chrétiennes pour ne pas faire
rougir l'histoire il y a un siècle le
génocide des acides syr a été ignoré il
continue à être méconnu comme le sort
des chrétiens d'Orient aujourd'hui
malheureusement à travers ce texte nous
parlons autant de l'histoire que de
l'actualité pour les chrétiens d'Orient
l'histoire bégaye ils se font toujours
face à la volonté de les éradiquer de
les éliminer de les effacer aujourd'hui
dans le monde selon l'Église en Détresse
un chrétien sur 7 et fortement persécuté
et discriminé dans le monde soit 360
millions d'entre eux en raison de sa foi
aujourd'hui encore le président Erdogan
fait régulièrement allusion de façon
extrêmement méprisante et menaçante à ce
qu'il appelle les restes de l'épée les
résidus de l'épée faisant directement
allusion à l'épée qui a massacré les
chrétiens d'Orient en 1915 cela désigne
de manière abject les survivants des
génocides et cela menace aussi de
poursuivre cette extermination hier
comme aujourd'hui nous sommes face à une
communauté désarmées petit en nombre
mais majestueuse par sa culture hier
comme aujourd'hui nous sommes face à un
peuple qui devient le bouc émissaire
d'une radicalisation instrumentalisée
par ceux qui veulent imposer par la
force la violence un régime qui n'a rien
à voir rien à faire avec une religion
mais tout avoir avec la conquête du
pouvoir l'assouvissement des pires
instincts humains mais contrairement au
génie Sud d'Arméniens reconnu par de
nombreux pays organisations
internationale est considérée comme l'un
des quatre génocides officiellement
acceptés par l'ONU le massacre des
asturocaldéens
souffre d'un manque de reconnaissance en
tant que génocide lui-même si comme le
dit le président de la République la
France veut regarder l'histoire en face
elle ne doit oublier personne ce manque
de reconnaissance est sans tête dû au
fait que la nation a syrienne est
souvent méconnue d'ailleurs l'Europe n'a
jamais placé le sort des chrétiens
d'Orient au premier rang de ses
priorités et ses regrettables parce
qu'ils sont minoritaires parce que nous
dépendons énergétiquement de de certains
pays pour nos sources
d'approvisionnement parce que l'Europe a
mauvaise conscience en raison de sa
lourde responsabilité dans les conflits
qui ravagent le Moyen-Orient depuis la
fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale nous
avons appris aujourd'hui de nos erreurs
nous avons payé le prix de nos fautes et
parce que nous sommes à la fois les
protecteurs historiques des chrétiens
d'Orient mais aussi le pays des droits
de l'homme c'est génocide du 20e siècle
comme du 21e siècle ne doivent pas faire
face à la passivité de la communauté
internationale pour qu'il y ait
aujourd'hui une protection de ces
populations la lutte contre la barbarie
doit mobiliser ensemble des pays du
monde nous devons reconnaître ce
génocide les actes commis par les forces
ottomanes il y a plus d'un siècles comme
ils sont commis aujourd'hui par daesh
doivent être considérés comme un crime
de génocide et comme un crime contre
l'humanité et là aujourd'hui nous ne
pouvons que déplorer la passivité de
l'ONU pour la protection de ces
minorités victimes de torture et de
purification ethnique c'est pourquoi il
est impératif que la plaine déposée par
la Cour pénale internationale par la
coordination des chrétiens d'Orient en
danger aboutissent ban Kimon alors
secrétaire général de l'ONU affirmait le
20 juillet 2015 que les actions a tenté
contre les chrétiens pouvaient être
considérés comme un crime contre
l'humanité mais il s'agit d'un véritable
génocide comme je l'avais dénoncé à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est génocide
sont aussi la matrice de notre
civilisation et nous oblige à agir au
nom de l'histoire et des engagements de
la France comme l'explique Joseph Yacoub
ce génocide physique cette spoliation
des terres et des biens était
accompagnée d'atteindre grave à
l'héritage culturel et malheureusement
ces exactions se poursuivent comme
aujourd'hui en arc Sark les aciers rock
aldériens se sont vus dépos d'une grande
partie de leur lieu de vie de leur
culture de leur mémoire en tout plus de
400 églises et monastères ont été ruinés
plus de 250 000 assuro caldéa Siriac ce
qui représente plus de la moitié de
cette population ont péri des mains des
Turcs et des irréguliers Kurdes
utilisées à ses fins aussi notre texte à
plusieurs objectifs nous demandons
notamment au gouvernement de reconnaître
officiellement l'extermination de masse
de déportation et la suppression de
l'héritage cultuel de plus de 250 000 à
sirop calvéens par les autorités
ottomanes entre 1915 et 1918 comme chez
lucide nous invitons aussi à condamner
publiquement ce génocide et à faire du
24 avril la date de commémoration
annuelle du génocide arménien et du
génocide acérocaldéen et ceux qui
parlent de concurrence des victimes à
ceux qui parlent de cette concurrence
des victimes je la réponds
l'universalité des victimes
l'universalité de la cause
rappelons-nous cette phrase délivisielle
qui disait en ayant l'existence d'un
génocide en l'oubliant on assassine les
victimes une seconde fois avec cette
résolution nous donnant à la France
d'aspirer ses voisins européens et plus
largement les démocraties
occidentales nous leur demandons aussi
de rester éveillé sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pour que ces exactions ne
continuent plus ne continuent plus à se
perpétuer dans l'indifférence générale
en votant cette résolution mes chers
collègues je vous remercie d'ailleurs de
vous associer à cette résolution je vous
demande de marquer de nouveaux
l'histoire en considérant les
acérocaldéas non plus comme un peuple
classé en marge de l'histoire mais
désormais comme un bloc inséré dans
l'histoire et si vous me permettez de
conclure en rappelant ces mots de
Patrick Devedjian lorsque le génocide de
1915 avait été reconnu à l'Assemblée
nationale nous leur devons se linceul de
mémoire nous leur devons cette dignité
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur André guillol
pour le groupe RDSE
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme l'ont
appelé les auteurs de la proposition de
résolution la reconnaissance du génocide
à sirop caldéen s'inscrirait dans la
suite de cette de ce génocide des
Arméniens de 1915 porté par la loi du 29
janvier 2001 un génocide son procédé son
but c'est l'extinction en toute partie
d'un groupe ethnique religieux ou racial
c'est la pire abomination de l'humanité
nous portons tous la même appréciation
sur ces moments tragiques de l'histoire
bien entendu il faut condamner les
massacres perpétrés entre 1915 et 1918
contre la communauté acier rocadéenne
syriaque
un peuple réduit du fait de sa faible
population contemporaine mais riche de
sa culture et immense par les gloire qui
l'assument ou qu'il rappelle un peuple
poussé à la marginalisation et contraint
à l'immigration
un peuple ayant presque entièrement
périt sans que l'Europe s'amuse et sans
que nul ni prêta intérêt plongé dans
l'oubli et dans l'indifférence générale
un peuple sans état que le climat
favorable au nationalité il y a de cela
siècle à oublier à abandonnant à leur
sort les quelques milliers de survivants
sans être engagé à apporter des
garanties pour la protection à sirop LD1
et autres minorités ethniques
religieuses à l'intérieur des régions de
l'Empire ottoman alors démantelés Paris
a finalement rendu caduque tout accord
intervenu or à l'heure du règne des
États-nations sans son propre état d'un
peuple d'un point de salut l'idéologie
nationale qui s'immense les états
récemment constitués privilégie souvent
à l'excès l'appartenance au groupe
ethnique majoritaire entre les
miettement en microcommunautés et un
ordre d'étatique négateur des
particularismes minoritaires la France
doit jouer le rôle de porte étendard et
d'état démocratique et protecteur des
minorités
néanmoins avant de porter notre
réflexion avec toute forme de
reconnaissance il est important de
rappeler la controverse entourant la
qualification de génocide et le rôle du
législateur d'un Sacquet de la juste
vérité historique rappelons que
reconnaître l'effet inventé par des
historiens n'est pas refaire l'histoire
et regardera bien on se gardera bien
d'avoir des positions à géométrie
variable si les aciers
n'ont jamais connu semble-t-il le
bonheur des peuples sans histoire leur
massacre répond indiscutablement à
minima à la qualification d'un crime
contre l'humanité cependant au-delà de
la retenue ou non de la dénomination de
génocide je ne souhaite pas que sans
consensus nos actes mémoriels incite à
une guerre de mémoire et à une
concurrence des victimes il y a eu il y
a encore tellement de malheurs
d'atrocités d'exaction de guerre et de
conflits qui ont jalonné et jalonnent
encore notre histoire il ne faut pas
qu'il y ait concurrence mais
universalité des victimes
nous n'avons pas être sélectives or il
nous appartiennent reconnaître le
génocide arménien et désormais assis au
caldéen sur quelle base refuserions-nous
de reconnaître aussi celui des Tutsis au
Rwanda mais la liste est si longue
scruter l'actualité néanmoins la
reconnaissance du génocide acéocaldéen
dont le massacre fut je le rappelle
avéré en son temps par la Société des
Nations doit constituer un jalon majeur
pour la justice et la lutte contre
l'impunité sous toutes ces formes au
Moyen-Orient orients comme partout
ailleurs dans le monde cet acte mémorial
ne doit pas stigmatiser culpabiliser
exclure ou diviser les populations
actuelles en qualifiant de génocidaire
les descendants des coupables et des
exactions au contraire l'effet établi de
manière définitive doit faire l'objet
d'une acceptation unanime et servir de
fondement à la réconciliation
si les souffrances des Arméniens
principalement attirer l'attention de la
communauté internationale au siècle
dernier ce texte va même dans le sens
des récentes évolutions en la matière en
effet ce sont consécutivement
l'Association internationale des
spécialistes des génocides l'Allemagne
et le Saint Siège qui ont consacré
l'extermination concertée des aciers
auxquels des reins par l'empire Ottoman
de 1915 et 1918 comme génocide toutefois
je terminerai mon propos en vous
rappelant la polémique qui avait suscité
la proposition de la loi de 2012 adopté
ici au Sénat en entendant condamné les
négations des diuno aussi de reconnus
par l'État français dont celui des
Arméniens
avait en effet provoqué des tensions
diplomatiques graves entre la Turquie et
la France or si le contexte ne doit pas
interférer sur ce qui est juste je doute
que le moment soit opportun pour raviver
les tensions entre nos deux états alors
qu'en Kara endeuillé fait face
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il y a une
importante catastrophe de ces quatre
dernières années et nécessitent tout
notre soutien c'est pourquoi le groupe
RD se fidèle à sa diversité et attaché à
sa liberté de vote sans remet à
l'appréciation de chacun de ses membres
qu'une majorité approuvera je vous
remercie
la parole est au président Bruno
Retailleau pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
mesdames Messieurs chers collègues
je voudrais commencer parce que j'ai
entendu l'intervention précédente pour
redire au niveau de mon groupe LR la
compassion que nous éprouvons
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des deux peuples
de peuple turc mais aussi le peuple
syrien de façon claire de façon très
nette et tout à l'heure si au cours de
mon propos je devrais parler de l'Empire
ottoman de Monsieur Erdogan
du rôle de la Turquie encore aujourd'hui
c'est pour parler d'un régime ça n'est
pas pour parler d'un peuple je distingue
le régime et je distingue le peuple
chers amis chers collègues c'est une
résolution importante qui nous réunit en
quelque sorte une démarche historique à
travers cette résolution
nous avons voulu avec Valérie Boyer et
tant d'autres posaient deux actes deux
actes importants un premier acte de
reconnaissance mais aussi un acte de
résistance
l'acte de reconnaissance il est
nécessaire il a été
explicité par les deux intervenants
précédents
qui chers collègues aujourd'hui c'est
encore qu'entre 1915 et 1918
plus de la moitié de ce peuple à sirop
caldéen fut rayé de la carte qui
aujourd'hui
c'est ton corps
qu'il s'agissait à l'époque de plus de
250 000 hommes femmes enfants et
vieillard
qui furent massacré massacrer dans des
conditions qui sont terribles de mort
violente atroce de mort lente à petit
feu abandonné sur les routes de l'exode
de la déportation à travers les déserts
brûlants d'amésopotamie
cette réalité
on doit la reconnaître aujourd'hui on
doit d'autant plus la reconnaître que je
voudrais rappeler à la Haute Assemblée
que ce crime génocidaire il est
contemporain d'un autre génocide le
génocide arménien j'ai décidé que nous
fume ici la première assemblée en
première lecture à reconnaître il y a
près de 23 ans sous l'impulsion à
l'époque du président Jacques Chirac le
génocide arménien les deux sont liés ces
morts sont liés et je pense que il y a
une logique à ce que la reconnaissance
avance aussi désormais pour ce petit
peuple sans frontières sans État petit
peuple né grande histoire
à sirop adéenne
c'est bien sûr un parallèle qu'on peut
tracer entre ces deux histoires parce
que
de ces deux peuples peuples Arméniens
peuple astérocaldéen la mécanique fut la
même la mécanique génocidaire
il y a eu des exécutions méthodiquement
appliquées mais surtout
méticuleusement planifié ils furent
massacrés non pas pour leurs actes non
pas pour ce qu'ils firent à l'époque
pour ceux qui étaient
un peuple qui n'était pas sûr
qu'autrement un peuple qui n'était pas
musulman un peuple tout simplement
chrétien comme il s'en est trouvé
beaucoup dans cette région du monde il y
a plusieurs siècles et le racine
plongeait extrêmement profondément dans
cette géographie dans cette histoire
particulière comme pour les Arméniens il
a fallu que les auteurs notamment
Ottomans et leur supplétif a jusqu'à
l'effacement de leur culture la culture
disait quelqu'un c'est le plus court
chemin de l'homme à l'homme et quand on
veut détruire un peuple on cherche à
effacer l'empreinte culturelle à
détruire tout ce qui peut ressembler à
une architecture des églises des
monastères
une culture
dans toute sa profondeur mais le
parallèle s'arrête là puisque si pour
l'Arménie nous avons reconnu
solennellement le génocide il n'en fut
pas le cas pour les acérocaldens sans
doute parce que c'est un peuple qui
n'est pas doté d'État sans doute aussi
parce que il y a eu des résidences je
les entends s'exprimer à nouveau
vis-à-vis
du successeur de l'Empire ottoman de la
Turquie c'est donc premier de ces actes
dans cette reconnaissance
un acte de vérité au regard de
l'histoire
mais c'est aussi un acte de résistance
un acte de résistance aussi bien face au
négationnisme
mais aussi au fatalisme négationnisme à
un moment où l'histoire dans le monde
sur la planète est instrumentalisé
négationnisme il faut prononcer le nom
de Monsieur
Erdogan aussi bien d'ailleurs pour le
génocide arménien que pour celui-ci et
si aujourd'hui monsieur Erdogan cherche
à réécrire l'histoire c'est que il
cherche à reconstruire l'Empire ottoman
et tous les régimes autoritaires
procèdent de la même façon
réécrire l'histoire faire la guerre pour
essayer d'accomplir des dessins
impérialistes et puis il y a le Fatalis
certains pourraient être contentés de
nous dire mais vous savez
c'est loin c'est un petit peuple encore
une fois sans état sans frontières
faut-il s'en préoccuper bien sûr qu'il
faut s'en préoccuper
bien sûr que ce peuple là où il se
trouve aujourd'hui rassemblé dans
l'ancienne Babylone à une histoire
multicellulaire mais ce que je voudrais
surtout vous dire c'est que ce peuple la
première fois que je suis allé en Irak
c'était quelques semaines quelques
semaines après la proclamation par
Monsieur albac Dadi de Mossoul du
califat c'est peut-être en août 2014 tel
premier parlementaire à me rendre en
Irak et j'ai vu les traces vivant de ce
peuple j'ai vu un peuple qui est
évidemment moins nombreux là où il était
depuis des siècles et puis des
millénaires
qu'il naît dans la diaspora dispersé
dans toute la planète aujourd'hui mais
j'ai vu son courage j'ai vu sa
résistance par rapport à Adèle j'ai vu
aussi les efforts de ce peuple
qui n'avait cessé au cours des âges de
génération génération de jeter des
passerelles
culturelles y compris religieuse entre
toutes les communautés c'était souvent
le seul point et le seul trait d'union
entre ces communautés religieux quelle
fut je voudrais salué d'ailleurs la
figure du cardinal Sako qui est le
patriarche ses églises et ceux qui
connaissent son action savent l'action
aujourd'hui de cette communauté à sirop
caldéenne notamment dans l'Irak actuel
donc pour conclure bien sûr je vous
proposons la reconnaissance l'adoption
de cette résolution c'est pas au nom du
passé c'est au nom de l'avenir de leur
avenir l'avenir d'un peuple certes sans
état n'est pas sans mémoire nous ne
pouvons pas mes chers collègues les
laisser seul avec leur malheur mais
aussi notre avenir au moment où encore
une fois l'histoire est en proie avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'idéologie et il me
semble que cet avenir nous concerne
aussi bien sûr 100 ans plus de 100 ans
après cette tragédie il est trop tard il
est trop tard pour sauver les victimes
il est trop tard pour punir les
coupables les bureaux
déjà mettre trop tard pour dire les
choses il n'est jamais trop tard pour
rendre justice aux victimes d'hier et
aux vivants d'aujourd'hui
la
parole se Joël guerriot pour le groupe
Les Indépendants
après séisme qui a frappé à la frontière
Turco syrienne je veux rappeler notre
soutien peuple kurde syrien et turc avec
une pensée émue pour les victimes et
leurs familles il y a plus d'un siècle
la Première Guerre mondiale a pris fin
ce conflit a été d'une ampleur et d'une
violence jusqu'à leur inconnue qu'il est
aujourd'hui difficile de se représenter
cette guerre qui aurait dû être la
guerre d'eder a fait près de 20 millions
de morts en massacrant ses enfants
l'Europe s'est suicidée selon le bon mot
de Romain Rolland même si la cessé
depuis plus de 100 ans se confie
continuent de produire des effets cette
guerre a en effet marqué la fin du temps
des empires tant en Europe qu'en Asie
Mineure et au Moyen-Orient elle a
également décidé les populations des
plus grandes puissances du monde mais
comme trop souvent dans l'histoire une
tragédie en a entraîné une autre
alors que les regards étaient fixés sur
les combats du théâtre européen la
Turquie
ottomane engagée dans le conflit aux
côtés de l'Allemagne a profité de la
guerre pour régler ses comptes en 1915 à
la perpétrée un génocide contre les
populations arméniennes alors qu'il a
été maintes fois décrit et documenté
Ankara refusent toujours de le
reconnaître l'ampleur des massacres leur
caractère ciblés et systématique ainsi
que la volonté d'effacer ce peuple sont
pourtant indiscutables les Arméniens
n'ont pas été les seuls à faire l'objet
de massacre par la Turquie
ottomane en cette année 1915 les aciero
caldéens ont eux aussi subi des
déplacements forcés et des exécutions en
masse cette population comptait un de
mes millions de personnes à la fin du
19e siècle la moitié d'entre eux ont
disparu dans les massacres
à ne pas reconnaître le passé en
secondaire à le revivre les auteurs de
la présente proposition de résolution
rappelle à juste titre que les chrétiens
d'Orient ont figuré parmi les premières
victimes de l'État islamique nous ne
devons pas laisser dans l'ombre ces
crimes contre l'humanité la proposition
de résolution que nous examinons
aujourd'hui invite le gouvernement à
reconnaître le génocide perpétré par la
Turquie contre les assyrosaldéens
reconnaître ce génocide satisfait un
double objectif tout d'abord un objectif
de justice les massacres dont ont été la
cible à sirop caldéens en 1915 sont
effectivement constitutifs d'un génocide
ces actes ne peuvent pas rester sans
condamnation la justice condamne de
reconnaître la souffrance des peuples
commande plutôt le second objectif
poursuit est un objectif de protection
reconnaître ces massacres quand le
génocide comme le génocide qu'il
constitue mais en lumière des
populations qui étaient encore récemment
victimes de persécution une
reconnaissance mettrait en lumière à la
fois les assyrockéens et le menace qui
pèse sur eux la communauté
internationale serait trop plus dès lors
plus attentive à leur sort un lieu de la
Turquie toujours candidate à l'entrée
dans l'Union européenne nous attendons
de ce pays qui agissent dans le respect
des valeurs humanistes or après avoir
acquis des S400 russe Ankara n'a pas
hésité à illuminer une frégate française
ne l'oublions pas hélustre du chantage
migratoire contre l'Europe et bloque
l'adhésion des pays européens à l'OTAN
la Turquie n'hésite pas non plus à
recourir à la force contre ces minorités
et celle de ses voisins nous avons su
nous avons vu son action contre les
Kurdes de Syrie en Irak ces agissements
graves sont particulièrement
préoccupants loin de reconnaître son
passé
semble vouloir continuer à effacer ce
qu'il la dérange un comportement que
plusieurs régimes autoritaires ont
adopté à travers l'histoire toujours
avec des conséquences funestes dans ces
conditions et regarde la longue histoire
qui nous lie avec les chrétiens d'Orient
et nous semble que la France doit
contribuer à empêcher de nouvelles
actrosités cette rose édition défend
utilement dans la victoire tant la vie
la mémoire des victimes concernées que
la survie de leur descendants les
membres du groupe Les Indépendants
voteront donc en faveur de l'adoption de
cette résolution merci de votre
attention
la parole est à monsieur Guillaume
Gontard chers collègues monsieur le
président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
qu'il me soit permis avant d'évoquer cet
épisode dramatique de l'histoire du
Proche-Orient d'avoir une pensée émue
pour les dizaines de milliers de
victimes du séisme qui a frappé la
Turquie et la Syrie pour leur famille et
leurs proches pour celles et ceux qui
sont encore coincés dans les combles
c'est les ceux qui tentent de les sauver
et celles et ceux qui désespèrent de
revoir l'être aimé
notre collègue Boyer et le groupe LR
nous propose une proposition de
résolution pour la reconnaissance du
génocide à sirop caldéen permettait
d'abord de noter comme notre collègue
tema récemment quand nous proposons à la
majorité sénatoriale de réparer par le
droit une faute commise par la
République à l'endroit notamment des
soldats fusillés pour l'exemple de la
Grande Guerre le groupe LR nous accuse
de vouloir réécrire l'histoire mais que
la chose ne vous pose nullement problème
quand il s'agit de proposer loi et
résolution mémorielle sur l'histoire
d'autres pays une contradiction de plus
pour notre part nous n'avons pas de
problème de principe avec le vecteur
législatif comme outil de politique
mémorielle histoire est une matière
mouvante une construction à la fois
scientifique sociale et politique qui
évolue avec le temps à mesure des
découvertes de l'étude des archives et
de l'évolution du point de vue que lui
porte les sociétés avec toute la rigueur
scientifique indispensable à l'exercice
il me paraît normal que le Parlement se
penche sur notre histoire la période sur
laquelle vous nous invitez à réfléchir
compte parmi les plus pratique et les
plus douloureuses de notre histoire
parmi toutes les horreurs de la Première
Guerre mondiale celles commises par
l'empire Ottoman puis la Turquie
naissante continue de hanter nos
mémoires
au 19e et 20e siècle l'Empire ottoman
regroupe une population Magic
majoritairement musulmane ainsi qu'un
ensemble de minorités chrétiennes de
diverses églises sismatiques considérés
comme des citoyens de seconds de
secondaire pardon notamment les
Arméniens les Assyriens les Syriaques
les Yazidi les caldéens les Grecs
pontiques fréquemment victimes
d'exactions et de massacres en 1909 le
mouvement nationaliste des Jeunes Turcs
arrivent à la tête de l'empire et
cherchent à imposer sa politique de
turquisation qui prend de l'ampleur avec
le début de la Guerre mondiale pour
éviter la fracturation de l'Empire et la
révolte des populations chrétiennes
soutenues par l’ennemis russe les
autorités turques musulmanes ont mis en
place un véritable plan d'extermination
de ces derniers au total entre 1 et 1,5
millions de personnes sont tuées dans
ces massacres et des centaines de
milliers déplacés
dans les racines sont à la fois
politique
identitaires et religieuses comme
l’oubli un peu trop l'exposé des motifs
de la présente résolution sont
communément reconnus sous l'appellation
de génocide Arméniens qui fait l'objet
d'un consensus historique très large et
d'une reconnaissance politique
importante qui n'inclume malheureusement
toujours pas la Turquie si la réalité
des populations non-musulmanes et non
turques de l'Empire ottoman dépasse la
seule population arménienne et s'il ne
fait pas de doute que toutes ces
populations ont été massacrées sans
distinction par le pouvoir
ottoman peut-on pour autant distinguer
et parler de génocide à sirocaldéen
selon la définition du génocide de la
Convention des Nations Unies il faudrait
pour cela que les assis recaldéens
représentent un même groupe national
ethnique raciale ou religieux pareil
affirmation ne fait pas l'objet d'un
consensus historique et mériterait un
colloque bien plus savant que notre
débat du jour les populations à
syriennes syriaque ADN même si elle
partage une langue commune
peuvent-elles être considérés comme un
même peuple
ce n'est pas le choix retenu par les
très rares pays qui reconnaissent
distinctement la logique génocidaire des
massacres et qui comme par exemple la
Suède ou les Pays-Bas distinguent les
Assyriens les Syriaques les caldéens et
qui inclut également les Grecs pontiques
également massacrés et étrangement
absents du périmètre de la présente
proposition vous l'aurez compris faute
d'un consensus historique plus large il
nous semble que la loi du 29 janvier
2001 relative à la reconnaissance du
génocide arménien de 1915 inclut dans
son spectre l'ensemble des massacres
opérés par l’empire ottoman sur la
période concernée et satisfait donc
largement toutes les demandes de la
présente résolution mais si tel n'est
pas la vie de la majorité sénatoriale
pourquoi ne pas nous proposer une
proposition de loi pour compléter ou
préciser la loi de 2001 plutôt qu'une
PPR nous n'ayant pas le caractère
systématique des massacres opérés contre
les populations non turques mais
considérant que la réflexion qui
sous-tend la présente PPR n'est pas
encore aboutie et n'oubliez pas et
n'oublions pas un contexte géopolitique
complexe et un contexte human dramatique
en Turquie le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire s'absiendra sur
la présente proposition merci monsieur
le Président la parole
est RDP
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre cher collègue tout d'abord en
premier lieu au nom de mon groupe RDPI
j'ai une pensée émue et une profonde
tristesse pour la Turquie et la Syrie et
pour toutes les familles des plus des 10
000 victimes au dernier des contes qui
ont péri dans les terribles séismes
survenu dans leur pays
rappelons tout d'abord quelques éléments
historiques pour le sujet qui nous
réunit comme la rappeler précédemment
donc mes collègues dans différentes
interventions la population à syrienne
du nord de la Mésopotamie dans les
régions sud-est de l'actuel Turquie et
nord-ouest de l'Iran a été déplacé de
force et certains de ces membres tués
par les forces ottomames entre 1915 et
1918 les estimations sur le nombre total
de morts varie de 180 000 à 275 000 le
sujet arménien a longtemps
occupé le devant de la scène peu de
chercheurs se lancait à l'époque sur le
sujet assuro Calder c'est très cette
résolution a porté mémorielle n'est
qu'un texte purement déclaratif qui
n'aurait qu'une portée symbolique ce
n'est pas un véhicule législatif opérant
une quelconque amélioration pour les
milliers de chrétiens encore persécutés
en Orient ni pour les descendants des
assuroscaléens du début du 20e siècle
sur le fond le dispositif prévu par la
PPR est assez simple mais l'exposé des
motifs les centres voir une autre
volonté une phrase en particulier doit
interroger je cite comme en 1915 les
victimes sont chrétiennes et les
bourreaux musulmans
par une extension de sens cela revient à
sous-entendre que les musulmans sont
toujours les coupables cet amalgame
renforce tous les sentiments négatifs
qui existent à l'égard de cette religion
il est dommageable qu'un sujet
historique d'une telle complice
complexité soit passé au travers d'un
filtre déformant et simplificateur pour
l'opinion publique l'enjeu est simple
reconnaître un fait pourtant la réalité
est plus complexe précaution sémantique
sur la définition du génocide agenda
politique concurrence mémorielle
relation diplomatique multilatérale nous
ne sommes pas un face à un nœud gordien
à trancher avant de repartir étudier un
autre texte le coeur serein la politique
mémorielle passe aussi par des actions
qui peuvent avoir un caractère
symbolique très fort tels que des
discours de chefs d'État le président de
la République Emmanuel Macron a déclaré
la France c'est d'abord et avant tout ce
pays qui sait regarder l'histoire en
face qui dénonça parmi les premiers la
traque assassine du peuple arménien en
réalité le problème est ailleurs le
président le président de l'Union des
asturoscaléens de France le fait
comprendre clairement les acides
se sentent oubliés c'est une question
d'égalité dans la reconnaissance au-delà
de la question de vérité au cours des
années 1990 avant les premières
recherches universitaires sur les seyfo
les groupes de la diaspora assyrienne
ont commencé à communiquer auprès de
différents gouvernements en décembre
2007 l'association internationale des
chercheurs sur le génocide à adopter une
résolution reconnaissant le génocide
assyrien les parlements suédois en 2010
puis les parlements Arméniens
iné-erlandais en 2015 ainsi qu'allement
en 2016 ont suivi pour autant très peu
d'états se sont engagés
dans cette voie on ne peut donc pas dire
que la majorité des États est acceptée
cette démarche ni qu'elle fasse
consensus puisqu'il Israël est le
Royaume-Uni ont refusé de voter une
disposition similaire à celle que nous
étudions aujourd'hui pour autant nous
sommes depuis longtemps les soutiens et
les amis des chrétiens d'Orient en tant
que vice-présidente du groupe de liaison
avec les chrétiens d'Orient et
vice-présidente du groupe d'amitié inter
parlementaire france - Turquie j'ai fait
de nombreux déplacements sur les
territoires nationaux correspondant à
l'ancienne Empire ottoman j'ai par
ailleurs eu l'occasion d'échanger aussi
avec la communauté turque de mon
département ces personnes n'ignorent pas
le sujet asturo caldéen et ils sont très
sensibles évidemment il faut le dire la
France est toujours montrée solidaire
des minorités opprimées du Moyen-Orient
par la voie des membres du clergé comme
l'avait Eugène Grisel ou l'archevêque de
Paris mais aussi par celles d'élus à
l'instar de Denis Cochin députés de
Paris et membre de l'Académie française
depuis le 16e siècle la France a été
attentive au sujet des assyros caldéens
lors de la Conférence de la Paix à Paris
en
1919-1920 plus récemment devant les
défenseurs des chrétiens d'Orient ce
mardi 31 janvier dernier à l'Elysée le
président de la République a annoncé le
doublement des fonds destinés à soutenir
les écoles chrétiennes au Moyen-Orient
créés en 1920 se font avaient déjà
soutenu 174 écoles l'année dernière
soutenir les chrétiens d'Orient est une
mission historique et un engagement
séculaire de la France
le président de la République nous ne
pensons pas que ce texte dont l'exposé
des motifs comporte des raccourcis et
des parallèles plus que discutables
contribuent utilement à la relation si
importante et singulière entre la France
et les chrétiens d'Orient pour ces
raisons et parce que le sujet relève de
l'appréciation individuelle de chacune
et chacun le groupe RDPI adopte une
position d'abstention avec liberté de
vote je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Rachid temal pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
si vous allez au plus haut c'est mieux
c'est plus haut
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame auteur de la proposition
de résolution cher Valérie Boyer mes
chers collègues alors que nous apprêtons
à discuter d'une résolution d'une
relative à la reconnaissance par le
gouvernement d'un génocide
permettez-moi de dire quelques mots sur
suite autrementaire qu'il y a ces
dernières heures frappé la Turquie et la
Syrie en effet ce si février ce sont
bien deux séismes à 9h intervalle du
Maïti de 7,8 sur les salles de Richter
pour le premier de 7,5 pour le second
avec un épicentre la ville de gaz en
tête qui ont durement frappé les
populations alors on parle il y a plus
de 11000 morts qui sont déjà recensés le
nom de l'essai sera beaucoup plus
important vous l'imaginez bien c'est une
course contre la montre qui est lancée
pour tenter de retrouver les survivants
prise au piège des débris on demande
impactés par les températures glaciales
à jamais ces femmes ces hommes et ses
enfants sont marqués touchés dans leur
chair et dans leurs âmes par ces
événements je vais au nom de mon groupe
leur dire tout notre soutien et le
redresser nos sincères condoléances nos
pensées sont tournés versus la France
côté des peuples turcs ici rien qui
souffrent
chassis bien évidemment donc sans rien
qui de parent leur histoire familiale
vivent en France leur pays et qui sont
pleinement angoissés par la situation et
attendent des nouvelles enfin je
souhaite souligner la formidable
solidarité internationale qui a su se
mobiliser agir la France il prend toute
sa part nous pouvons que le remercier et
saluer l'action du Président de la
République à cet égard
mes chers collègues ce mercredi 8
février
2023 est un mot attendu pour ne pas dire
espérer et ce depuis bien longtemps trop
longtemps par la communauté à
siroccalienne je parle là de nos
concitoyens pleinement français et
j'associe d'ailleurs les membres de la
communauté qui risquent aujourd'hui en
Irak en Turquie pardon ou en Irak ou
ailleurs et qui en cet instant observe
le Sénat
oui ce mercredi 8 février du 23 il nous
revient par nos votes de reconnaître
leur histoire leur histoire
douloureusement marquée par ce génocide
en cet instant je souhaite dire quelques
mots à celles et ceux qui s'interrogent
sur le sens même du vote de cette
résolution
je pourrais leur répondre que l'histoire
de France est aussi celle d'un pays qui
a toujours pris ses responsabilités pour
protéger les chrétiens d'Orient je n'ai
pas ici revenir sur l'ensemble de
l'histoire le temps me manque mais il
faut le rappeler je souhaite également
saluer l'action des présidents de la
République Monsieur François Hollande et
Emmanuel Macron qui ces dernières années
ont eu agir en accueillant des réfugiés
assez caldiens menacés de morts par
daesh ils ont été à la hauteur de leur
mission nous devons les en remercier je
pourrais également leur dire que la
France a toujours fait le choix de
protéger les minorités ainsi que leur
culture et leur histoire sans
distinction religieuse que ces peuples
soient de confession chrétienne
musulmanes ou juive je pourrais enfin
ajouter que il y a plus de deux siècles
la France a fait le choix de devenir la
patrie des Droits de l'Homme et faire de
l'universalisme pardon son champ de
réflexion et d'action permanent
je me dois aussi de leur dire que la
position de mon groupe n'est pas de
peser à travers cette résolution sur les
relations diplomatiques avec la Turquie
avec la Syrie ou toute autre État du
Moyen-Orient notre position ne s'inscrit
pas non plus dans une quelconcologie de
guerre de civilisation ou de matrice
civilisationnelle car l'une comme
l'autre sont infondées et mortifères mes
chers collègues il ne s'agit pas pour le
Sénat d'écrire l'histoire c'est le rôle
et la mission des historiens
laissons-les travailler pour autant le
rôle du Sénat est bien de prendre acte
de l'histoire et si l'histoire est
claire le génocisation par la puissance
Thomann est Avery
près de la moitié des 500 000 à
sion-calédiens ont été pourchassés tués
massacré supprimer par la puissance
ottomane leur maison leurs églises
furent détruites et leur bien confisqués
ce génocide est bien le premier du 21e
siècle du 20e siècle
c'est bien j'ai aussi au sens de la mise
en œuvre date dans l'intention de
détruire intégralement ou en partie un
groupe national ou ethnique ou raciale
ou religieux tel que définie par la
Convention de l'ONU du 9 décembre 1948
les écrits sur le génocide des 115
existent et sont parvenus jusqu’à nous
des écrits tant sur la plume sous la
plume pardon d'observateurs mais aussi
de bourreaux des bourreaux eux-mêmes la
presse française d'ailleurs à l'époque
écrivait pour raconter et dénoncer les
atrocités de ce génocide
les témoignages des victimes elles-mêmes
existent et seg en héritage cette
mémoire de justice se transmet et voyage
elle se transmet de génération en
génération comme j'ai pu le constater
elle voyage au gré de l'exil de leur
village montagneux à la nouvelle
capitale
dans mon département du Val-d'Oise
40 ans après
40 ans après leur premier arrivé dans
notre pays aujourd'hui leur pays nous
pouvons saluer leur amour de la patrie
leur volonté farouche de faire grandir
la République sans jamais oublier leur
histoire leur culture leur langue ainsi
que leur sœur et sœur leur frère et sœur
qui sont encore là-bas
avant de conclure je souhaite dire
quelques mots à mes collègues va partir
de droite de l'hémicycle comme je l'ai
fait il y a quelques jours le débat sur
les fusillés pour l'exemple si le Sénat
peut prendre acte de l'histoire ce coup
de faisons aujourd'hui avec émotion et
responsabilité l'histoire de France de
prendre en être exclu
aussi mes chers collègues il permet aux
témoin d'associer évidemment celles et
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui ce soir dans
les tribus du Sénat je pense notamment
au conseil de mon conseil de
coordination des assureurs de France
avec les présidents Georges yarami c'est
Jean-Marc Cabasse mais également la CF
ou Joseph Yacoub permettez-moi donc de
les associer parce qu'ils sont là parce
qu'ils portent depuis des années leur
mémoire le mémoire d'un peuple la
mémoire de la souffrance donc le groupe
socialiste écologistes Lucien votera
bien évidemment ce projet de résolution
qui invite le gouvernement reconnaître
le génocide c'est un premier pas
qu'il faut noter et saluer mais nous
devons aller au bout du processus en
effet la résolution si je dis c'est un
premier pas et je le salue et je
remercie celles et ceux qui l'ont déposé
n'a pas de valeur contraignantes aussi
c'est pourquoi notre groupe le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain du
Sénat déposera très prochainement une
proposition de loi visant à reconnaître
le génocide acier au caldéen et à faire
du 24 avril la date de sa commémoration
le même jour que celle de celui du
génocide arménien qui est aujourd'hui
reconnu par la loi bien évidemment je
vois le Président nous sommes ouverts
puisque on déposeront à le travail
ensemble nous déposerons
et ben nous disposons nous notre texte
en cette heure vous avez parlé d'une
résolution
mais comme toujours cher président
c'est comme toujours sa présence dès
qu'il s'agit de l'intérêt supérieur de
la nation et de l'humanité ce que nous
ferons mais nous voulons aujourd'hui que
nous irons non plus loin que le projet
de réduction ici présenté je doute pas
que le Sénat donc adopra cette
résolution il aura donc à la faire
adopter dans les mêmes termes par
l'Assemblée nationale je ne doute pas là
aussi que le Président le premier
ministre le président de la République
la Premier ministre et bien sûr la
majorité relative à l'Assemblée votre a
je pense que si le groupe également
elle est la vote les socialistes
voteront je crois que aussi l'Assemblée
nationale pourra adopter dans les mêmes
termes cette loi-là dès lors dès lors
dès qu'elle sera adoptée elle deviendra
à force de loi la reconnaissance sera
cette fois-ci totalement effective et le
24 avril sera totalement une journée de
coloration de ce génocide là et ainsi et
seulement assis le long combat pour la
mémoire et la vérité sera totalement
victorieux
pour conclure permettez-moi de reprendre
les mots de Victor Hugo qui siégé sur
les bancs du Sénat ici juste à côté où
vous êtes assis chers collègues servir
la patrie est une moitié du devoir
servile humanité et l'autre moitié c'est
le chemin qui est devant nous dorénavant
je vous remercie
si monsieur
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues Walter
Benyamine disait que le progrès humain
ne peut se réaliser tant que la justice
n'a pas été rendue aux victimes des
persécutions nous devons aux morts du
génocide arménien alors souffrance et à
leur mémoire qu'une instance juridique
internationale établissent l'effet et
les culpabilités comme les Juifs de la
Shoah les Bosniaques de ce serait
benitia et les Tutsi du Rwanda les
victimes du génocide des déportations
des spoliations perpétrées par l'empire
Ottoman qu'elle soit arménienne grec
quantique ou aciero caldéenne doivent
être reconnus par un tribunal pénal
international sous mandat de
l'Organisation des Nations Unies la
recherche historique a montré depuis
longtemps que le génocide arménien de
1915 n'est pas un accident mais la phase
paroxysmique une administration de plus
en plus criminelle des minorités
religieuses ethniques par l'empire
Ottoman pour bien en mesurer
l'importance il faut rappeler que les
Arméniens Grecs Juifs syriaques à syrien
et caldéen représenté plus de 19% de la
population
ottomane en 1914 contre
0,2% aujourd'hui la construction de
l'État turc que moderne s'est nourrit de
la persécution des minorités religieuses
ethniques les minorités chrétiennes ont
été éliminées les premières puis vint le
tour de celle qui fut considérée comme
incompatible avec l'identité nationale
fondée sur le sunnisme et la turcité
ainsi une violente campagne antisémite
aboutit à l'expulsion des Juifs de
traces en 1934
progressivement les minorités
religieuses issues de l'islam subir elle
aussi la persécution chiite
et ensuite les allervies n'oublions pas
les massacres comiques entre les
communautés à Lévis de civas en juillet
1993 et de plusieurs quartiers
d'Istanbul en mars
1995 enfin comment oublier le destin
funeste du peuple kurde auquel le traité
de sève promettait un territoire
autonome au sein duquel serait reconnu
des droits pour la minorité à sirop
caldéenne son article 62 stipulé en
effet que sa mise en oeuvre devait je
cite comporter des garanties complètes
pour la protection des acérocaldens et
autres minorités ethniques ou
religieuses dont l'intérieur de ces
régions on sait ce qu'il a le vin de ce
traité que la France et le Royaume-Uni
s'en pressèrent de remplacer par celui
de Lausanne signé en 1923 qui organisa
leur tutelle sur les possessions
automanes du Proche-Orient et abandonna
l'Arménie et les kurde à leur ressort pi
ce traité permit la réalisation de ce
que la partie turque qualifiable je cite
stabilisation de l'homogénéité
ethno-religieuse et qui se traduisit
dans les faits par l'expulsion d'un
million et demi de Grecs de Turquie un
tiers d'entre eux mourir avant
d'atteindre les côtes grecques ce
génocide des Grecs de Turquie ne doit
pas non plus être oubliée le Traité de
Lausanne a posé les bases de l'identité
religieuse ethnique du nouvel État turc
un ministre de la Justice de Mustafa
Kemal Atatürk déclarait en 1930 je le
cite que tous les amis les ennemis et
aussi les montagnes sache bien que le
maître de ce pays c'est le Turc ceux qui
ne sont pas de pur turques n'ont pas un
seul droit dans la patrie turque c'est
le droit d'être le serviteur c'est le
droit à l'esclavage
la France accepta tout jusqu'à
l'opprobre de céder à la Turquie en juin
1939 le sanjak d'Alexandrette qui
appartenait au territoire de la Syrie
placé sous son mandat les 50 000
Arméniens Grecs et asyriens qui vivaient
prirent eux aussi le chemin de l'exil
dans votre résolution chers collègues
vous écrivez que la France a un devoir
historique et moral de protection des
minorités chrétiennes d'Orient
l'histoire nous enseigne malheureusement
qu'elle ne l'a assurée que lorsqu'il
pouvait satisfaire ses ambitions
géopolitiques ce pragmatisme sans
scrupule a considérablement affaibli ces
communautés et en tout premier lieu
celle des aciers
sans doute parce que la diversité de ses
composantes linguistiques religieuse
ethnique la rendait encore plus fragile
minoritaire parmi les minoritaires
persécutés parmi les persécutés oubliez
parmi les oubliés les aciers
auxquelséens n'ont cessé de subir les
conséquences des bouleversements de
l'histoire tumultueuse du Proche-Orient
la France en reconnaissant le géolocide
Arméniens qui ne concerne pas seulement
les Arméniens ne les a pas ignorées la
mérite le mérite de cette résolution et
de les associer plus distinctement à
l'hommage rendu à tous les morts du
génocide je vous remercie merci chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur François Bonnot
pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
une pensée pour commencer pour de la
part de notre Groupe pour toutes les
victimes des terribles tremblements de
terre de Turquie et de Syrie
et tout son cortège de drame humain qui
qui se déroule actuellement au cœur de
l'hiver
qui sont absolument terribles
dans son ouvrage daté 1920
les aciers et les Arméniens
massacrés par les Turcs
Joseph niehem un ancien homonier des
prisonniers de guerre alliés en Turquie
et officiers de l'instruction publique
transcrit des témoignages des victimes
des atrocités de l'Empire ottoman mais
également des témoins oculaires
alors que le tribunal de la Conférence
de la Paix allait se prononcer sur le
sort de cet empire déchu son objectif
était de faire connaître au juge et à
l'opinion publique l'asservissement
depuis des siècles de chrétiens
d'Arménie en Asie Mineure et en Syrie en
apportant ces témoignages Joseph niehem
a souhaité graver dans le marbre la
mémoire d'un peuple oublié il dit
notamment
j'ai à cœur d'établir le martyrologe
d'un petit peuple le plus intéressant
mais en même temps le plus abandonné
issu d'un grand empire de la plus
ancienne civilisation du monde dont le
pays fut comme l'Arménie le théâtre des
abominations turques dont les hommes
furent tragiquement assassinés les
femmes les enfants et les vieillards
déportés au désert pillés martyrisé
soumis au pire outrage ce peuple c'est
le peuple à sirop Calder
durant la Première Guerre mondiale
l'Empire ottoman décimait les
populations arméniennes et les
aciroscadéens se rendant coupable de
crimes contre l'humanité alors que l'un
était reconnu comme un génocide par la
loi du 19 janvier 2001
la reconnaissance de l'autre est
toujours suspendue plus de 100 ans après
les faits
la Convention pour la prévention et la
répression du crime de génocide de 1948
et pourtant clair à ce sujet elle énonce
plusieurs critères dans son article 2
quant à la définition d'un génocide il
est reconnu ainsi que les actes commis
dans l'intention de détruire ou tout ou
en partie un groupe national éthique
racial ou religieux il peut s'agir d'un
meurtre une atteinte grave à l'intégrité
physique au mentale une soumission
intentionnelle ou encore d'un transfert
forcés d'enfants exode famine
déportation violent à culturation ou
encore conversion forcée voilà ce qu'on
subit des victimes à cirocadéennes de
1915 à 1918
les massacres se déroulaient dans un
périmètre très vaste en un atelier
oriental en Perse dans la province de
moussoul c'est-à-dire dans des lieux
identiques à ceux ou périssaient les
Arméniens dans les deux cas les
nationalistes turcs souhaitent éliminer
des groupements turcs et non musulmans
de zone géographiques trop sensibles en
les exterminants en les dispersant ou en
les déportant afin d'homogéniser
l'Empire nul doute n'est permis s'agit
bien à génocide nous sommes la France le
pays des droits universels des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen il est notre
héritage il est de notre honneur de
reconnaître ce génocide en dehors de
toute haute considération vis-à-vis du
pays qui n'y s'est fait reconnaître
publiquement et officiellement est une
manière de ne pas occulter ses drames et
ses massacres et à l'égard de ces grands
oubliés dans l'ombre des victimes
arméniennes
alors que les yeux du monde étaient
tournés sur les événements de la
Première Guerre mondiale en Europe
l'Empire ottoman assurément su profiter
de la conjoncture pour se débarrasser de
ces hommes de ces femmes de ses enfants
qui ne demandaient qu'à vivre sur ce sol
comme leurs ancêtres depuis des temps
immémoriaux
sous la Turquie de Mustapha kennal les
communautés à sirop LDN ont été
marginalisées ces questions ne pouvaient
pas émerger au niveau collectif et sur
le plan politique à cause du
nationalisme ambiant turc comme arabe ce
n'est qu'à partir de des années 1980
qu'un débat s'est ouvert sur ces
massacres par le biais des enfants et
des petits enfants de la diaspora les
autorités turques actuelles
issues d'ancien Empire ottoman refuse
d'admettre leur responsabilité et leurs
actions génocidaires face à des
minorités culturelles et religieuses
s'il est toujours nié par Ankara au même
type que le génocide arménien le
massacre des aciers rockadéens est
aujourd'hui reconnu par la Suède le
Parlement hollandais l'Australie
l'Arménie ainsi par le Vatican
en 2023 il n'est plus acceptable que
l'État turques refusent de ne pas
confronter à cette treille cruelle
réalité historique celle qui a coûté la
vie à plus de 250 000 aciers en 3 ans et
réduit en esclavage des milliers
d'autres
leur est venue d'une reconnaissance
officielle de ces crimes pour ce qu'ils
sont c'est-à-dire un génocide cette
connaissance est indispensable et pourra
permettre de créer une lame de fond afin
qu'un jour le gouvernement turc l'admet
à son tour l'histoire des Nations est
bâtie de fée glorieux et il est aussi il
est de la grandeur d'un peuple de
l'admettre
triste de constater que bien souvent
pour les minorités l'histoire est
cyclique elle se répète
l'ostilité à l'égard de ces populations
restent prégnantes dans ces régions à
titre d'exemple l'engagement politique
et militaire de la Turquie avec
l'Azerbaïdjan contre les Arméniens au
carbac à mi annule le passé révélé la
gravité du traitement des minorités
chrétiennes
comment ne pas rapprocher le massacre
des acides du XXe siècle et des tueries
meurtrières des chrétiens et des Yazidi
d'Irak et de Syrie par daesh ces
dernières années
les motivations et les contextes
politiques sont certes différents mais
les conséquences sont similaires des
événements laissant des milliers de
morts et qui ont ébranlé les fondements
même de la vie de l'ensemble de ces
communautés
dans ces deux cas des groupes
minaritaires religieux étaient ciblés de
manière systématique en raison de leur
foi et ont été soumis à des violences
extrêmes ils ont été condamnés sans
autre issus avec deux seules
possibilités celle de fuir ou salle de
mourir
la reconnaissance du massacre des aciers
en tant que génocide et la condamnation
des actes de daesh contre les
populations chrétiennes et Yazidi sont
des premiers pas importants pour faire
face à ces crimes contre l'humanité et
pour prévenir leur répétition dans
l'avenir oui cela fait plus d'un siècle
mais ne nous disons pas qu'il est trop
tard car cela serait une erreur une
nouvelle erreur il n'est jamais trop
tard pour rendre hommage aux victimes en
reconnaissant l'existence du génocide
nous honorons la mémoire des victimes et
leur sacrifices leur permettant de
maintenir leur identité culturelle et
religieuse il n'est jamais trop tard
pour préserver l'histoire en
reconnaissant le génocide nous nous
assurons que les leçons de cette
histoire ne sont pas oubliées et que les
drames du passé ne finiront pas dans
l'oubli
n'est jamais trop tard pour offrir une
justice aux victimes reconnaître le
génocide c'est apporter en quelque sorte
une forme de réparation pour la
souffrance et les sacrifices du peuple à
sirop caldéen en somme il n'est jamais
trop tard pour réveiller les consciences
la reconnaissance ne pourra que
sensibiliser l'opinion publique aux
causes et conséquences de ces tragédies
inciter d'autres pays à prendre des
mesures en ce sens la démarche portée
par madame la sénatrice Valérie Boyer et
monsieur le Président Retailleau est une
démarche importante il ne s'agit pas de
procéder à une réécriture de l'histoire
mais de reconnaître de mettre les mots
sur la vague meurtrière qui s'est
abattue sur ce peuple chrétien du
Proche-Orient le groupe Union centis
dans sa très grande majorité votre a
pour la proposition de résolution enfin
mes chers collègues je ne veux je ne
peux que vous encourager à la soutenir
il ne s'agit pas d'un vote mais d'un
acte réparateur un acte de justice pour
se souvenir de ce jeune aussi trop
souvent oublié je vous remercie merci et
je profite de votre passage en tribune
pour vous souhaiter un bon anniversaire
chers collègues
alors la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Olivier belge ministre délégué
chargé du Commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité et des Français de
l'étranger
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
madame la sénatrice Valérie Boyer
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs alors où les populations de
Turquie et de Syrie pleurent les
victimes du séisme du 6 février ou
cherche encore des survivants dans les
décombres je voudrais d'abord adresser
les pensées et les condoléances du
gouvernement au peuple de ces deux pays
la France d'ailleurs à l'heure à
laquelle je parle envoie son hôpital de
campagne de sécurité civile en soutien
au peuple concerné
s'agissant du projet de résolution qui
nous est présenté ce soir je voudrais
attirer l'attention de votre autre
assemblée sur l'amalgame hélas réalisé
entre les questions mémorielles de
l'Empire
ottoman qui relève du travail des
historiens et la situation contemporaine
des chrétiens d'Orient en faveur de
laquelle nous sommes évidemment
pleinement engagés les questions
mémorielles nécessitent un travail de
recherche approfondi permettant
d'éclairer des faits historiques ces
questions ne peuvent être débattues que
la lumière d'une telle analyse qui
participe au travail de mémoire sur les
événements tragiques de notre passé afin
d'établir la reconnaissance du crime de
génocide une lecture juridique est en
outre nécessaire la définition du crime
de génocide renvoie en effet un corpus
juridique international précis désormais
établi par la Convention pour la
prévention et la répression du génocide
les statuts des tribunaux pénaux
internationaux pour le
et bien sûr de la Cour pénale
internationale nous devons aussi tenir
compte des différences de contexte et
nous ne pouvons pas examiner cette
proposition de résolution sans tenir
compte de l'exposé des motifs qui la
justifie en 1915 les victimes des
massacres auxquelles se réfèrent le
projet de résolution était toute
chrétienne il en va différemment des
événements des dernières années si les
chrétiens ont à l'évidence été la cible
des atrocités de daesh des membres
d'autres communautés ont été ciblées
comme les yeidi les chiites ou les
sunnites que l'organisation terroriste
considérée comme déviants de fait c'est
parmi les musulmans que les victimes de
daesh sont en plus grand nombre
nous avons besoin pour protéger les
chrétiens et les membres des autres
minorités de l'engagement des
gouvernements concernés mais aussi des
populations musulmanes majoritaires qui
elles aussi souffrent du terrorisme
affirmer ainsi qu'en 2023 les victimes
sont chrétiennes et les bourreaux
musulmans relèvent d'une vision
partielle et partiale de l'histoire à
laquelle le gouvernement ne peut
souscrire
c'est notamment la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement ne soutiendra pas ce
projet de résolution
la France agit ainsi
sans doute plus que n'importe quel autre
pays en faveur des chrétiens d'Orient ce
soutien est pluric séculaire et
s'inscrit dans une longue histoire
d'amitié avec les communautés
chrétiennes d'Orient c'est l'accord dit
des captilations concluent entre
François 1er et Soliman le Magnifique
qui confiant en 1536 à la France le
privilège et la responsabilité de
protection des catholiques de l'Empire
ottoman si ces instruments juridiques ne
sont plus en vigueur sauf en Israël et
en Palestine la France conserve une
responsabilité politique et morale en
faveur des chrétiens d'Orient comme l'a
dit le président de la République a
plusieurs reprises se passer nous oblige
notre pays continue donc d'agir en
faveur des chrétiens d'Orient et des
autres minorités du Proche et du
Moyen-Orient il le fait
par fidélité à des populations qui sont
proches de nous par cohérence avec son
engagement en faveur des droits de
l'homme en particulier de la liberté de
religion il le fait également par
conviction le maintien de la diversité
religieuse au Moyen-Orient est une
condition indispensable à son évolution
vers la paix la stabilité la tolérance
et la prospérité c'est pourquoi notre
pays s'engage pour toutes les minorités
au Moyen-Orient ainsi la France a pris
l'initiative d'une réunion du Conseil de
sécurité qui a en mars 2015 avant
d'organiser en septembre de la même
année une conférence internationale pour
la protection des victimes de violence
ethniques et religieuses au Moyen-Orient
le plan d'action
issu de cette conférence reste une
boussole pour la communauté
internationale
à titre national la France agit aussi je
veux ici mentionner quelques exemples de
notre action tout d'abord nous apportons
un appui financier important pour
prévenir des vidences religieuses dans
la région entre 2015 et 2022 la France a
ainsi mobilisé le Fonds de soutien aux
victimes de violence ethniques et
religieuse au Moyen-Orient à hauteur de
39,4 millions d'euros pour financer 123
projets notamment en Irak et en Jordanie
ces projets portent sur la santé eau
hygiène assainissement soutien
psychologique santé moyen de subsiste de
subsistance et sur la stabilisation des
minages relancent économiques
conservation du patrimoine culturel
à la demande du Président de la
République nous avons créé un fond pour
les écoles d'Orient ce fond présente la
particularité d'être cogérée et que
financer par le ministère de l'Europe et
les affaires étrangères et l'œuvre
d'Orient ONG catholique bien connu en
2022 se font à distribuer 4 millions
d'euros d'aide aux écoles
confessionnelles qui diffusent la
francophonie au Proche-Orient en
particulier au Liban son action sera
reconduite pour le même montant en 2023
la violence peut être aussi immatérielle
pour cela la France s'engage également
dans la protection du patrimoine
culturel et religieux des chrétiens
d'Orient je pense au soutien que nous
apportons à l'Alliance internationale
pour la protection du patrimoine dans
les zones de conflits
LPH celle-ci a permis depuis 2018 de
mener une trentaine de projets de
réhabilitation du patrimoine en faveur
des chrétiens
à Mossoul au cœur d'une ville meurtrie
par des mois d'occupation par daesh Ali
LPH finance la restauration de l'église
caldéenne altaïra dont le dôme s'était
effondré la France s'engage aussi sur
son territoire en faveur de la
préservation du patrimoine culturel des
chrétiens d'Orient il a par exemple été
décidé en 2022 de créer un nouveau
département au musée du Louvre
consacré aux arts de Byzance et des
chrétiens théorientales je voudrais
aussi citer notre action de lutte contre
l'impunité des crimes commis en Syrie et
en Irak nous soutenons la documentation
des crimes et violations des droits de
l'homme coïn par daesh et l'ensemble des
belligérants et mettons tout en œuvre
pour que les responsables de ces crimes
puissent être traduits devant des juges
enfin nous entretenons un dialogue au
plus haut niveau politique avec les
autorités religieuses lors de l'audience
papale du président de la République à
l'occasion de sa visite au Saint Siège
des 24 et 25 octobre 2002 il a notamment
été question du maintien de la diversité
religieuse et de la protection des
chrétiens d'Orient le président de la
République la ministre de l'Europe et
les affaires étrangères nous
ambassadeurs sur le terrain rencontrent
les chefs religieux chrétiens et
musulmans
et les encouragent
à promouvoir une culture de paix de
respect mutuel de collaboration au
service du bien commun dans l'esprit du
document d'Abou Dhabi sur la fraternité
humaine signée conjointement par le pape
François et le grand imam d'alaza en
2019 l'avenir des chrétiens d'Orient est
aux côtés de leurs compatriotes
musulmans c'est pourquoi nous soutenons
le dialogue interreligieux et les
initiatives promouvant un islam moderne
tolérant et respectueux de la diversité
humaine et religieuse je vous remercie
pour votre attention
merci monsieur le ministre
nous allons procéder au vote sur la
proposition de résolution la Conférence
des Présidents a décidé que les
interventions des orateurs valaient
explication de vote
j'ai été saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe les républicains
sur la longue sur la proposition de
résolution relative à la reconnaissance
du génocide des acides de 1915 1918
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
58 du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
le résultat du scrutin donc nombre de
votants 337 exprimés 302 pour 300 contre
2 et bien donc la proposition de
résolution est adoptée
mes chers collègues
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 21h30 pour l'examen de la
proposition de résolution européenne sur
l'avenir de l'Agence européenne des
garde frontières et des garde-côtes la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]